do you believe filmmakers should focus
their efforts on film festivals or film
markets or are both two separate animals
well um that that fundamentally depends
on the film and it really does because
every Film Festival has a different feel
to it so when you like to submit to
Sundance for instance they are looking
for independent films but but they're
looking for a and I don't know if I can
express a problem but they're looking
for a certain feel of films like a
certain type of or style of film as as
Toronto as is Berlin so if you feel that
your film fits with the the culture of
that Film Festival then the film
festival is definitely the way to go but
before going into the film festival like
anything else you got to do your your
your work I would strongly suggest
having people lined up who know people
at the festival so that way you when you
go there you don't get lost so if your
film does make it to a festival you
should at least know programmers you
should have your PR person with you so
that way it's not just lost you can
actually get some traction from it maybe
you might even find a distributor at a
film festival so use that as like as
your you know as your Normandie you know
prepare for it you know that's that's
your landing and it's really important
you got to do prep and prep so if you
get into a film festival then you know
focus all your efforts around I'm
talking about the a-list festivals so if
you're gonna get into an a-list festival
and your film fits that well great then
I think that's that's beautiful but if
your film is like more mainstream if
it's more mainstream where in the sense
you are doing like action films for
instance that maybe have been you know
told on a on a grand budget like by a
studio or something but you're doing an
action film in a unique manner then
maybe the markets are better because you
know you're not you're not doing so much
the art film which I think would fit
better with the festivals but you're
doing more of a mainstream film that you
think
might reach a broader audience perhaps
the market would be better you may be
able to find somebody who will
ally themselves with you like whether
it's a distributor or or someone who
knows you know how to how to sell a film
or a broker that perhaps maybe a better
way but but but it's hard to tell I mean
I'm not like I said it's a massive
learning curve and I'm still a bit
confused so but that's that's my take on
it
you